To Watch out about the scientist because,
because he said no,
the NASA plan, when he found
out what it was, what is,
it's a breakaway civilization where
you don't try to run the whole planet.
You Siphon off resources and build a whole
new advanced system and then you play
or body off against each other
and collapse it. So when I say,
what is an Assa if we could take NASA
back over, it's bigger than the CIA.
It's the real government, the space
ships and the stuff that's all PR.
NASA is the real government.
NASA,
there were two breakaway governments to
shadow governments and Brad talked about
Saturn Garber 20 years ago.
So it's in,
it's in the documents and so you had
one that was British run and the Germans
came to the, our own us elite and said,
hey, you always need a couple of plants.
They said, we've got all this
on the drawing board, the EU,
a plan to poison the food water
to get rid of the dumb people,
a plan for Offworld basis.
We've got, by the way,
we're taking hardcore drugs and
we're in contact with aliens.
How has it given us tech? It was the
Germans first got in touch. Well,
how'd they do it? They were
really a cult bridge, right? Yeah.
Really into the culture.
That's what all the Indiana,
which is a shit around him at all times.
So human sacrifices. Oh Shit. Yeah.
The real society. What I am
telling you, Joe, this is not me.
You go to the real deep phd
level history books. Okay.
NASA is the German breakaway government.
Just always the Germans,
the Brits fighting for dominance.
So what you're saying is when operation
paperclip acquired all those Nazi
scientists,
they essentially started running NASA.
So Nasa became like almost like an
offshoot of the German government.
This offshoot government. Yeah. The
Germans had piled all the wealth away.
They had everything. So they
make, does that make sense though?
That in 2019 that's still
going on? No, no, no, no.
The British intelligence
doesn't run the CIA today.
The British empire was under
attack and just bankrupted itself.
And World War wine. It said, we'll
give you the keys of the kingdom.
Churchill wrote three books. Uh, the, the
history of the English speaking peoples,
he was half American and
this is officially in books.
We merged with the British
empire and like 1930 covertly.
Okay. That's what the CFR is. British
intelligence that US intelligence.
So the u s runs the show. Okay,
so you've got, you've got,
but German intelligence came
to Eisenhower and say, listen,
you don't need to do all this. You, we
haven't given them the real technology.
We're in contact with aliens and
they've never the whole plan,
where are you getting this from the
stadium so confidently it's in the
literature man.
Hitler like would go literature,
mainline historical books about answering
this assess castles where they go,
the aliens want blood.
So they'd killed like 20 kids and
everything's aliens would like come in and
he'll kill,
they taking the blood brings him in like
sharks and then they will not give them
technology. They go, this is how it works.
You build the atomic weapons this way.
He built it and they would like show
him bombers and like the aliens are like
telepathic. I don't even believe this.
This is what the nausea believed.
And the and the aliens with MindMeld
and give them the technology.
They're bad aliens so they
are you surprised the Nazis
were influenced by demons?
Know if demons are real. Definitely
think they'd be on the side of the Nazis.
But Joe, what I'm telling
you, if the aliens media,
no media is going to attack this.
I'm giving you want to know where I
can read it? Where can I read that?
Those statements because they
were in contact with the aliens.
Obviously your pockets,
Brill Society,
the Ar Group,
a chick [inaudible] right up there with
them, like doing ritual for three hours.
If acting fly here with
a report the day before,
I'll send it all to you with
mainline books. I'll see.
I'll mail the books with the tabs in
them. Okay. And I'll mail documents. Okay,
cool. Yeah, I'd love listen.
I think that they are absolutely
obsessed with the occult.
That's been pretty well documented. They
made flying saucers and I think, yeah,
and I think many,
many governments,
they developed a more advanced
form of nuclear fuel, heavy water,
and we had to shit in special forces on
suicide missions back when was really
special for us is to blow it up.
And I'm telling you,
the Germans had all
sorts of advanced shit.
They just couldn't ever keep the plants
from getting blown up because they were
a few years behind. Yeah. And by the late,
uh,
Churchill wrote about this in his memoirs
and said the Germans were way ahead.
It wasn't, the Germans were
bad that there's not such
a bad, but it wasn't that,
it wasn't the Germans that first
bomb civilian targets. In 1941,
the Brits were losing the war.
Hitler was bombing their for their
medical facilities and military facilities
and,
and so they went and bombed
German towns and German shit.
He's like, uh, I was the
famous German city Dresden.
What was the designated
a safe city for kids.
Half a million people died in one night
to trick Hitler to turn his bombers on
the general population. Then they tricked
him psychologically to do it. But, but,
but, but Churchill, this
has been declassified. It's,
it's, it's an esoteric books.
It's admitted. So Hitler was set up. Well,
there was bad. But here's what happened.
Albert Speer was he as chief armaments
and architects administered at British
trouble.
Agent Rudolf Hess was the deputy fuhrer.
They got Hitler totally love you.
Never hear about him since 1941 cause
they had a peace treaty with Edward the
eighth,
who was the king of England,
who was a Nazi and who was
German parish family, German.
And they had a deal to stage the attack.
The French stood down.
Vichy French didn't fight.
They put,
they put Nazi occupiers in the Dunkirk
operation was allowed to evacuate.
Edward the eighth was supposed to then
sue for peace through Neville Chamberlain.
But it's come out that it was all
set up by Churchill and others.
Not that they ran Hitler. They
weren't bad. They were pretty good.
But they master manipulated him.
And it never Chamberlain all of them and
bet on the British people in America to
come in. They had deals
with, uh, with, uh, with, uh,
Roosevelt to then bring us into the war.
And that was the whole master plan.
And you can actually go to
the history and see all that.
And that's what's so incredible,
Joe, when you, when you,
when you have all this info
and so Rudolph Hash in 1941 42,
he flies a one man bomber.
He was a world war one fighter.
Aish like the number three, eight, like a
hot 107 aircraft. Look it up. Rudolph ash,
he flies in,
parachutes into the castle.
The king was in at the time and like
northern England, I forget the name of it.
He parachutes in with the peace
treaty shine by the King of England.
They lock him up in the tower for
the rest of his life in London.
Okay.
And Edward,
the aide had to advocate type in Edward
d a Hitler and you'll see him in videos
or films and photos.
He was in Spain and World War II started.
Where do you think the contact
with the aliens came from? Where,
when did that start? All right.
This was the most important thing.
We're not aliens. Hold on. Hold on.
Inner Dimensional Aliens, alien.
It means anything. Not of this world.
What, when was, when did that happen?
That I sketched that
motherfucking fod code blues.
It's fake. I need to hear about aliens,
the guard, but I don't smoke marijuana.
Uh, yeah, that's marijuana.
You know what's crazy about aliens?
Is it a youtube made a big announcement
that they're going to go after at nine
11 videos. Anything. I Dunno
if this is true, I don't know.
But is it true that they're demonetizing
any videos that have truth or liberty
in them? Is that true? Yes, that's
true. But I heard that, well,
that sounds crazy interesting. Hold on,
let me finish. Let me finish real quick.
Uh, it's crazy how they're
going after nine 11.
Miracle Cure flatter and five,
they're blowing up alien videos.
They're blown on life. It's wonderful.
Strongest hold on. A ties videos out
there. I Dunno. But none of it's true.
It's true. Monetize. It is. Wow.
There's a lot of videos out there
than the best deals at the top.
Top of the line sponsored. No,
I'll tell you when Eddie's right.
I actually know the numbers.
The blowing up alien videos was a
little kid who makes $22 million a year
reviewing toys. No, no.
That's like the number one.
Isn't he like one of the
number one guys on Youtube?
It's like eight I'm saying alien
videos get monetized by fun.
High level sponsors.
The high level one because they're not,
they're not offensive. People get
drawn into them. Herman's Corinas up.
Why didn't they shut?
Not shut down?
Because they're talking about that the
government is lying and covering it.
Me because it's funny,
but it is.
How did the connection with aliens start?
You said this is the most important thing
you'd discussed on the podcast and any
I, I love you to death if you're awesome.
That's why I asked for you to be here.
If you want to believe in aliens,
I'm cool with that. I still love you.
I don't care. I don't care
about that. Listen, I'm, this
is not what I believe. Okay?
I love you for who you ought to do. I'm
trying to tell you something. Listen man,
let me tell you, Shawn, let
me tell you something. Okay?
I'm not making this stuff up.
I believe you believe it. No,
I mean the stuff I told you earlier about
my dad to the table being offered half
$1 million in 1980 [inaudible] that
build cyborgs and the marijuana.
He wasn't here for that
part. Okay. He came in later.
But tell me how the connection
with aliens cuts started
with who connection aliens and a notch
when people started becoming obsessed
with contact with the aliens.
Yeah,
he was saying in 1947 rounds we'll
have some sort of a connection.
You know Eddie's right.
They flood youtube and mainstream media,
like they always thought it was safe.
I thought about the private
Federal Reserve that he
wold order if I went on some
big show,
as long as they mix the aliens in with it.
And I was never the alien guy.
Right. I've never been the big alien.
He never years ago with you and
you know what I, that's right.
I remember when I was balls deep in
aliens cause I believed all that shit.
I believe it used to be that you'd be a
conspiracy theorist if you believe that
aliens, but amount anymore. But
now if you believe in aliens.